quien no he leído escuchado o al menos
oído hablar del principito la obra
maestra de la literatura que cuenta la
historia de un niño y su viaje
intersideral
suntech supera y escribió el libro en
nueva york' en 1942 y fue editado en
eeuu en inglés y en francés al año
siguiente en francia la editorial
gallimard lo publicó en 1946 ahora
cientos de dibujos acuarelas y
manuscritos han salido de la colección
estadounidense que posee los originales
desde 1968 y se exhiben por primera vez
en francia
se trata de varios esbozos o pruebas
donde vemos al principito con un perro
con un loro y en ausencia del famoso
zorro toda la búsqueda estilística de
sant exúpery era desconocida lo que es
muy conmovedor es ver hasta qué punto
necesitaba el dibujo para expresarse en
principio se le considera escritor y
aviador y ahora descubrimos que también
es dibujante de la exposición como
el escritorio aviador desapareció
durante una misión en el mediterráneo'
en 1944 y no conoció el éxito planetario
de su obra convertida en un clásico y
traducida a 498 lenguas 12
ediciones en lenguas con muy pocos
hablantes como él vásquez el idioma de
un pueblo ruso o el rapa nui el lenguaje
de la isla de pascua es la última
traducción conocida del principito hasta
la fecha
los estudiosos de la obra de suntech
superan y aseguran que el éxito de 'el
principito' se debe a su mensaje
humanista y universal que invita en
todos los rincones del mundo a
reflexionar sobre la cuestión del exilio